[Music]
so the point is when you think about how
chances and probabilities are given you
have to keep in mind what's known as the
base rate how often is the condition in
the population to figure out how much of
a concern how much of a concern you
should actually have okay now what I
want to do now is turn to something that
I think is a motivator for what people
often think of as signs of causation or
signs of something important and that is
coincidences okay so to begin with what
do we mean by a coincidence well
normally I think a coincidence is just
something that happens which is so rare
or unlikely that we just can't believe
that it would actually be due to chance
and that or and that we would be lucky
enough to see this rare chance event but
there's an important thing to keep in
mind about how we describe the event
that we're talking about so what I want
to do is put up a van anecdote here from
Richard Fineman who is the Nobel Prize
physicist who did a lot of fantastic
work at Caltech and so Lyman was this
incredibly charismatic individual and so
as he was started on off one of his
lectures he said you know the most
amazing thing happened to me tonight I
was coming here on the way to the
lecture and I came in through the
parking lot and you won't believe what
happened as I was coming through the
parking lot I saw a car with the license
plate a RW three five seven
can you imagine of all the millions of
license plates in the state what was the
chance that I would see that particular
one tonight amazing
that's incredible and what fineman's
trying to do here and I thought where
the point fineman's making is that
extremely low probability events happen
all
the time but the thing is we have to
realize that when it low probability
events happen all the time when
something is forced to happen and then
you go and you try to figure out
retrospectively what the chance of that
particular thing happening and that can
that can be misleading in this case of
the license plate so the Prada thing is
coincidences only appear coincidental
sometimes when you think about the
probability in retrospect and so this is
what a mathematician called persi
diaconis taught calls the blade of grass
paradox he says some Oh suppose I'm
standing in the middle of a large field
like out here at the how the light gets
in festival suppose I'm wandering around
I just put my finger on a blade of grass
well if you think about all of the
blades of grass here the chance of
picking the particular one you did is
phenomenally low but it's certain that
you're going to put your finger on a
blade of grass firstly diaconis is
really fantastic because he's a
mathematician but he got interested in
paradoxes and coincidences through the
most peculiar life history he did when
he was a teenager he ran away to join
the circus and he was in the circus for
a number of years before he then went
back to school and study mathematics and
he got interested in gambling and he was
hired by casinos to figure out how many
times you have to shuffle a deck of
cards before it you prefer to be random
and so on
really fantastic individual okay so now
here's the question I want to put to all
of you to consider okay and this is a
true story a New Jersey woman won the
lottery twice right if each lottery
offered a one in four million chance of
winning how likely it was such an
outcome okay so think about that so
oh say doesn't really matter say like
within and say um I think the actual
statistics were within a four month
period so say like within a four month
period she won the lottery twice um
you're right I mean if someone could
live infinitely often right and it's
probably less surprising that it would
happen in the course of a lifetime okay
okay depending on how often she enters
okay so one point six times ten to the
thirteenth okay one in sixteen million
okay very good
okay so what we're seeing here is that
this is just one of those miraculous
events so the you know if it's a one in
four million chance of winning and you
think of those as independent then the
way you would do that from probability
theory you multiply them and you get a 1
in 16 trillion chance of that occurring
okay that's pretty extraordinary but the
point is the actual chance about 1 in 30
not one in sixteen trillion okay why
okay why it's the blade of grass paradox
what's going on is when you think about
how likely is the such an event you're
thinking about the right answer to the
wrong question it's not a question about
how likely is it that that woman would
have won the lottery twice we're asking
the question out of all of the hundreds
of millions of people who play the
lottery in America and who play the
lottery repeatedly in America how likely
is it that one person would win the
lottery twice and that's the reason why
the odds are so fantastically low right
and so the reason why I mention this is
that if you think about coincidences and
you think well what would actually
motivate you to thinking about maybe
whether someone as engaged in fraud
whether they cheated maybe they had some
inside connections on the lottery board
if you think well a one in sixteen
trillion chance is so low shouldn't we
do an investigation to see whether or
not there is some fraud well
have to be careful about what this what
the calculation is okay another
coincidence
so diaconis writes so I had a friend
watching a James Bond film and there was
a four digit code on a bomb that matched
my bank accounts okay well here's the
thing you know there are 10,000 four
digit numbers if you know 120 numbers
you know credit card numbers phone
numbers pin codes and so on do the
mouths there's a one in four chance the
two of those will have digit four digits
that match that that number again a
coincidence that's not so coincidental
the principal that's I work here is that
when thinking about coincidences quite
often people don't specify in advance
where would count as a coincidence and
there are so many multiple end points
about what could count as a coincidence
that you can easily retrofit something
after the fact to be seen as this
remarkable coincidence okay and again
that can miss mislead people okay all
right so finally so I'm friend said you
know look my daughter myself my husband
all have birthdays on the 11th of a
month okay well how many birthdays does
a person have to know for there to be a
50/50 chance the three are on the same
day of a month
turns out you only need to know about
eighteen okay but now there are some
other examples of this which are quite
interesting so this is a point about
near coincidences so if you allow that
what counts as a coincidence to be fuzzy
they're much easier to find
take for example some variations on this
birthday question so
to begin let's take a look at his first
question how many people do you need for
there to be a 50% chance how many people
in a room like this do you need for
there to be a 50% chance that to have a
birthday on the same day okay so no one
else is going to write an answer then
apparently you all have already seen
this problem before because that 23 is
the correct answer so thanks to whoever
kind of spoiled the setup at that point
okay all right but what about this so
how many people do you need there to be
for there to be a 50% chance that two
people have okay someone else is already
and okay so okay so I'm thinking I might
just need to skip the rest of this
section okay so how many people do you
need therefore to be a 50% chance that
you have the birthday in the same way
okay so this is a little bit better but
the thing is if you look at the point
here so same day within one day or
within the same week 23 14 7 so
coincidences occur much more frequently
than you actually like where you would
expect and so the thing is we're very
prone to inferring causality from things
we think of as very low probability
because it just can't be an accident and
this can very easily lead us astray for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you